right before we go let's make this
week's visit to the big red chair hello
who's there
hi hi our thanks very good thanks so now
oh now are you from the Sweden no I'm
not I'm from Northern Ireland oh really
I have a very good ear in Sweden what I
used to live in Sweden for six months
see ya can you speak Swedish I can say
one one sentence is it disgusting no
okay go okay go ingen rectum tuck Oh
sagen you angular Eklund tuck it means
no junk mail please okay actually say
that again Anna klom okay yes I think
this is your I can't take anything
[Applause]
okay there's more where he came from
hello oh hello sir hello hi how are you
okay thanks good what's your name Toni
Toni lovely and where do you hail from
Toni London from London what do you do
I'm an accountant he's an accountant
there's no shame in it no not so Toni
the accountant from London off you go
with his story so this takes place in
1977 which was the year of the Queen's
silver jubilee you see would you believe
I must get a pen Toni and and we were
having a street party in a little
closed-in West in West Ealing yes yes
and a few months before this Phil
Collins of Newton's the case this
couldn't be more 1977 it was the time
when Genesis were at the height of their
fame we were all very excited my mother
was on the committee and she was
collecting money for the street part oh
she's great she's great yes she got to
Phil Collins's door and knocked on the
door and he answered and she explained
what she was doing and he gave us some
money and then he said to her what are
you doing for music because if you like
I could bring the boys round and she
said no that's okay thinks we've got a
disco
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'd get the onions out start chopping
she goes oh my god there's onions
all around he'll be like yeah everyone
understand okay yeah especially if
you're French its Lucas dubbing is a
talking dog great a dog it's a talking
dog it's a dog it's a talking dog